Minnesota senator Al Franken's political
future remains uncertain as he faces an
ethics probe in the Senate and growing
calls for his resignation in the wake of
sexual misconduct allegations President
Trump
weighed in on the scandal via Twitter
today he says the ALF frankenstein
picture is really bad speaks a thousand
words where does his hands go in
pictures two three four five and six
while she sleeps and to think that just
last week he was lecturing anyone who
would listen about sexual harassment and
respect for women Lesley Stahl taped
today the White House address criticism
of that comment some calling it
hypocritical for the President to tweet
about Franken and not about ROI more he
has weighed on the room and on Roy Moore
he did it while he was on a foreign trip
in Asia I did it repeatedly yesterday in
fact I took about 15 questions on that
topic and only one on Al Franken so to
suggest that this White House and
specifically that this president hasn't
weighed in is just inaccurate and wrong
Oh Kimberly I don't blame reporters for
asking about what seemed like a
inconsistency there but they the answer
is what it is she's basically saying I
think that they're sticking to their
guns are not gonna comment on it and
they don't police his Twitter he does it
himself but I don't blame the reporters
for asking what do you think they've got
to ask the question of course and I
think the answer is kind of consistent
with how they've handled things I mean
she's got to do her job and it's got to
be under the direction of the president
he really kind of speaks his own mind
he's his tweet speak for themselves he's
telling you how he feels and yes you
could say well he's comment on one but
not on the other so of course the other
side is gonna say this appears to be you
know an inconsistency but I will say
this the distinction I think with the Al
Franken case it just from speaking like
a prosecutor is when you look at the
facts and the evidence in front of you
there is an actual photographic picture
that shows what transpired she came out
and gave the statement he admitted it
apologized essentially so it's less of a
due process issue as to exactly what
happened and so many years ago etc etc
so I think it's more persuasive
compelling evidence perhaps a little
further along in the problems that was
one of the things one that also came up
in the briefing and the question about
the Al Franken had apologized for
allegations and allegations against
other
are just still allegations which is why
the attack was worthwhile your thoughts
on that well I don't think there's a
much in the way of saying that there's
an equivalence here because to my mind
there's a photograph of Al Franken
I guess he's positioning himself as if
he's touching this woman but we have a
tape from o5 of President Obama bragging
about what he does with women ifs if he
finds them attractive just kiss them
grab them
I'm sorry I'm sorry that's what you
accidentally said President Obama
President Trump Wow my brain is flipping
out President Obama I can't stop so I
and then you have you know the idea you
know 16 women who said that President
Trump was aggressive with them or
violated them in some way and we've
never gone through all that but clearly
President Trump thinks that that stuff
has been dealt with it's in the past the
American people elected him president
and he is not subject to it but I just
thought it was incredibly unwise of him
to open this door it was Pandora's Box
the throwing stones from my glass house
yeah well the Democrats have circled
around and for the most part backing out
Frank can take a look at this unwanted
sexual advances groping or harassment
are never okay they're never acceptable
never funny I think an ethics
investigation is absolutely appropriate
he's work with me and my colleagues on
both sides of the aisle but this kind of
conduct is totally unacceptable a
pourraient and repugnant and I think Al
Franken's apology recognizes it sexual
harassment and
is inappropriate in every circumstance
in every way whoever is involved so
let's start with that and I do support
that there should be enough that this
investigation and let's see where that
ends up this kind of behavior has been
swept under the rug for too long I will
tell you in general there is absolutely
no place for that kind of behavior in
the United States Congress so Pete
they're okay with the they accept the
apology they want an investigation and
other than that it seems like there
might not be anything more that happens
unlike other places like just this week
in PR CEO had to step down after
allegations that made people
uncomfortable and then he so he left a
actually lost his job so it's
inconsistent all across the board
depending on whatever industry you're
looking at very much so there is no
consistent standard you look at
Republicans and Democrats so the double
standard is rampant I mean maybe that
maybe the president hasn't called for
Roy Moore to step down but how many
Republican senators have dozens of them
telling him to leave the race or of
course
how many doc setters have called for Al
Franken to resign zero at this point and
what are they calling for an ethics
committee investigation those senators
called for Chuck Schumer has called for
it Durbin Klobuchar McCaskill even Fred
Franken himself is saying investigate me
in the ethics committee a couple of
facts about the Senate Ethics Committee
it really doesn't like himself what he
must no no he does like himself
and he wants to preserve himself because
here's what the Senate Ethics Committee
does over the last I'm warming up here
in the last decade the Senate
Intelligence Committee has has
investigated 613 allegations in this
committee 613 allegations over the last
decade 75 investigations all anonymous
no consequences without a single senator
has yet to be found any sanctions
against so yeah because all we don't
innocent no matter what the swamp at
work yeah I I realized that this isn't a
math heavy show haha try us but I mean
you're from Fox Business and also just
but but in fact yours is though instead
of a zero-tolerance policy there is a
100 percent tolerance policy if there is
no punishment or no responsibility meted
out to any one of these people was an
posturing policy now what's really
interesting here is this in
you're saying if they end up backing Al
Franken which I imagine they're going to
I imagine you know this is all a big
dog-and-pony show they've been given
their talking points they have to say
blah blah blah ethics investigation blah
blah blah including Al Franken has to
say the same thing because otherwise if
if they don't do anything it completely
neuters their argument against the
president and that's one of the favorite
Democratic talking points about the
president is his past political
correctness where does it end I also
think that the president I agree with
you he should be tweeting about Roy
Moore and he's got a political leg to
stand on because he can't say and he
loves being right I was the one who
backed Luther Luther strange that was a
much better choice if y'all had listened
to me you wouldn't be in this pickle so
when he tweet no more more often they do
the Y apostrophe ALL like you just said
it kind of y'all I think it would go
down I think he should also do that
every reporter that has to read the
tweet will have to say ya'll say bless
your heart to all the Republicans out
there who want to make a false
equivalency between the charges against
more dealing with a fourteen-year-old
girl and the charge or allegation here
against senator Franken no no no no I'm
saying well the idea is that this
picture that he's actually groping the
woman he's pretending oh if he's
pretending at least like there's a big
difference between what Al Franken is
being charged with and what we know
about I figure obviously right I think
that's right and I think there's an
important distinction to be made there
but and I also think that that's why
what Pete's saying is true Kimberly but
yeah that 43 US senators have said no
more and also President Trump is head of
the Republican Party the Republican
National Committee has withdrawn funds
from the races so in a way I think that
it's something that could have said at
the briefing today which is that the
party has spoken
the party has spoken I think yeah so
it's it's been handled and the party has
spoken very loudly and also with their
financial power and they've pulled that
back so I think there has been a very
Swift and judicious response from the
Republicans and I think it is clear that
there's hypocrisy on the part of the
left and the Democrats I mean again want
this guy he didn't like say I didn't do
it or it isn't me or it's my
doppelganger in the photo he's like I'm
sorry I did
okay and that's that I think there's a
big difference between Roy Moore and
Senator Franken but he means the
allegation both the nature of the
allegations but here's what's going on
candidly it's become like a team sport
it's like oh if you're a Republican or
will find a way to say don't don't say
anybody but it's a Democrat oh let all
hell break loose it's this ridiculous Oh
hypocritical Democrats say that the
party of women and the Republicans are
committing a war on women yet when
someone comes out with actual evidence
they say senator no we're you know what
about about Donald Trump's boat it's an
audio let me saying something as opposed
to these women in addition he jokes
about women let me just say to Kimberly
Kimberly the GOP of Alabama is still
backing Roy Moore Steve Bannon is still
backing Roy Moore Bannon is an
individual citizen he can do whatever he
wants then is your outrage at the
Republicans continue to support Roy
Moore Junction there the state GOP yes
you're right and look thought to deal
with the consequences of that if they
lose the race the and also just morally
but the RNC which of which the American
overseas did withdraw funds bigger deal
from Roy Moore and I think that that is
a statement but my only point was that
today one of the things that they could
have said at the White House is that we
have spoken money speaks loudly we are
not supporting this race that would have
been better but you know it's even
interesting to me Ivanka the first
daughter comes out and says there's a
special place in hell for people who put
these children breitbart comes out and
says Oh Ivanka should shut up she has no
place no standing to say difference I
think everyone has the right to say
something if you were offended if you
were outraged if you were moved by
something and she's a mom and she may
have a different perspective than other
people she absolutely has a right to say
that she's not saying you people of
Alabama absolutely have to force him out
that's right what does everything in our
power she's not effect
the race she's expressing an opinion and
why that's exactly right and why does
Juan Williams get to decide or any
politician in Washington DC let the
voters in Alabama decide let the voters
in Minnesota decide whether they that
want that person representing them
that's not I think what so many people
represent reject it's these elites who
are hypocrites themselves telling them
what they need well I think that well
without though is because the everyone
will be tarred with it and stainless and
every single ad going into 2018 and into
2020 will be tied to him and I think
that was the attempt initially would say
they they believe the women were
credible from the Washington Post piece
there been more to come there might be
still more to come on the Al Franken
story and the Congressional story is not
over right so and there are gradations
of all of this there are victims to be
considered like we don't talk a lot
about them but there are cultural and
political ramifications for both parties
know your side wants to be the one who
doesn't deal appropriately with sexual
harassment claims I think it's a bigger
gamble for the Democrats who've really
taken the high road in some of these
cases that hit awfully close to no but
they're saying it's because the
Democrats have stood up for women's
rights especially right but they're not
and I mean gosh it seems to me the
Democrats know they to returned a lot of
that money even now they're returning
money from Al Franken and Al Franken's
committee yeah but what I what I was
saying is the reason that the break mark
I was telling if I could trump the first
daughter - shut up was because it opened
the door just as President Trump did
last night with his tweet to people like
me saying hey wait a second are you guys
forgetting the charges against Donald in
the B blog so there's more because some